[Musique]
quand j'ai vu le premier j'ai été
époustouflé par celui-ci le premier film parle d'une
famille menacée par ces créatures
qui sont venues sur cette planète c'est
terrifiant et si tu fais du bruit tu meurs
[Applaudissements] des
atomes de ce que la famille a  un bébé et
ce bébé devient votre bombe à retardement,
cela ne s'arrête tout simplement pas et cette famille
est mise à l'épreuve,
s'il vous plaît, la deuxième partie reprend là
où nous nous sommes arrêtés, c'est-à-dire maintenant que le
système de sécurité a été modifié, ils
doivent partir et  commencer quelque part de nouveau, c'est
plus ambitieux et il y a plus de gens
avec plus de fonctionnalités et c'est comme un
train fou que
vous